let's go back to our breaking news this
morning a 23 year old man has died after
being stabbed in a nightclub in
Birmingham on Boxing Day a correspondent
Becky Johnson is live on the scene for
us and Becky just talk us through what
we know about what happened
really shocking news this it was on the
dance floor of the crane nightclub here
in digbeth in Birmingham that this 23
year old young man was enjoying a night
out with his friends last night when he
was stabbed on the Dance Floor now
police say they were called here about
11 45 last night
efforts were made to save this young
man's life but very sadly they say he
was pronounced dead around 30 minutes
later now his family have been told
they're receiving support and you can
see here at this nightclub cordoned off
while police carry out extensive
investigations they're trying to examine
any CCTV they're asking for anyone who
might have been filming in the nightclub
last night to get in touch with them
they say there will have been hundreds
of people in the Nightclub at the time
and whilst they've spoken to the
nightclub owner about what they saw
they're now also appealing for anybody
who was here at the time to come forward
especially if they saw anything or
filmed anything we've got some words
from detective inspector Michelle
Thurgood who's leading the investigation
she says this was a young man enjoying
himself with friends on a boxing day
night out and our thoughts with his
friends and family today she says we
know there were hundreds of people in
the Nightclub at the time while we've
spoken to a number of them already we
still need to hear from anyone who is
there and who witnessed or even filmed
what happened now she goes on to say we
believe that the victim was approached
by a group of people and was then
stabbed so we're working hard to
identify all of those involved now as
you can see this remains cordoned off
we've seen some scenes of crime officers
going in there to carry out forensic
investigation as they try to establish
just who did this
now back here I know you've just got
there but what is that area like around
there
it's an area that's popular with young
people going out there are a few bars
and clubs we're not very far away from
the city center itself so it's somewhere
where young people will know that's why
police have said they're going to have
uh extra patrols throughout the evenings
to come because people going out tonight
and in the nights to come over the
Christmas period in the lead up to New
Year are going to be feeling incredibly
anxious because as I say this is a
really popular night spot not far from
the city center where there are a few
quite newish clubs that have popped up
particularly popular with young people
in the area
okay Becky thank you so much
um for that and of course we'll bring
you the latest on that as and when we
get it but just to reiterate a 23 year
old man has died after being stabbed on
the dance floor of a nightclub in
Birmingham on boxing day